poi abbiamo scritto di cose signore
benvenuti sono euro video di famiglia
siamo su the great language game che
significa e l'italiano che vi traduco io
gioco della grande lingua avrete
consiste nella rosa di mister calma
abbiamo delle scelte qua a destra le
troviamo riconosce di base alla pizza
che sta poi tizio che sta parlando
che lingua sta parlando quindi in questo
caso può essere solo denis in di coreano
che il coreano e il thai che lo saprò la
leggo spesso nei siti erotici scritti
facciamo silenzio cosa su ducati non ho
capito però coreano facile mappa di pane
che ha poco da poco ammarati di liberti
fu da moto di rivolta il baghèt
considero che il consenso convinto state
quasi liberty e di una chiusa out of
tunes fu compier playoffs e tonga smw
sport on the song lo smom le assemblee
generali proclami ha preso un di calcio
il riso la declamazione fuga hanno preso
a olio dai telegiornali lega ma che
cazzo ajax e roma dalla consente al
francese mi parte sempre il film di
quella vecchia canzone techno
[Musica]
a sta cascando la luce
minchia si ritrovasse dei vecchi video
sarei rovinato era una cella youtube ai
tempi o meglio c'era ma io ho cancellato
in tempo è male ragazzino avanti che
tanto i testi fu d'amore per te de
france de france movie cube obi design
22 ma io direi anche italiano comunque
c'è gente è la mia era l'unica parla
così ciao vari l'ammiro e chat limbo
circolati grazie alla mia risposta alla
standard cazzetta mills è un fiume
cinese mandarino tua madre a vietnam
mese dall'uscita non è un tumulto del
cancer bengali e quello che l'anci per
rilevare la tua posizione
quando sei militari quindi bengalli quel
punto la de mer putin e parenti è
parente di blender che genchi for pataky
a chi scheidt ori pataky chi si è già
portata che a chi ora pataky a chi
quindi uzbeki norden il
ragazzo capace con le liguri
questo lo dicono solo le ragazze
sospensiva si badi in terminale ha
sentite tempo e ne sarebbero spanish by
un personaggio particolare però rimane
con l'atmosfera un po magica di un
avviso a indovinare pure il dialetto
personaggio particolare propensione a
giovanardi donare un po bische nostro
personaggio sangue
però alla fine si fa vedere perché ci
sono tante inquadrature tanto se uno
straniero sente stava non capisce in
mare anche l'italiano il figurativo di
toscano locatio tutte reali della
fashion le reali e un chiamati da the
same che dai non capisco più questo
alcuno di prima pietra mese fa
i drive dsc mancina character ulev reyes
cari se riconosco a 3 per i lep a
listini eni lo stato un loro proprio
romania romeni a vice amir ma del padre
ex teleco bucasse tipo teletu solo della
concorrenza
[Musica]
rossetti che ancora sto settiche ma che
minchia ci proverò va detto ha detto ha
detto fact that the counter affanculo
quella roba lì ma dai ma che cazzo e 24
di intorno al dynamic ma sembra che si
voglia vendere l'enel i braccialetti
dell'interno al banalmente meglio porta
a 22 euro 59 ghali venga ricurva mattia
mouse scappare come pure questo stavamo
e forse no tamil da madre da milano mi
piaceva ma ci sono più abitanti ad
abbiategrasso gatta mille secondo me 61
milioni meter esttp by skalka non so
manco lega lingua parlata e per nulla
che il tour
tutto questo è drogato per nulla che il
tour swahili genovese ma perché gli
altri anche tpp chebat ppd pbd di ppp
vargas aggiungi ppe parli urdu mydas è
il tpp chi monya the power chiede che i
tipi ppp sempre bene come di cpp urto
sempre e come tgv nell'aria ma non sarà
restaurato di ieri fare un tentativo sul
gioco che siamo bravissimi tutti
let's play game ragazzi mi mancava un
uomo nudo boxing midwifery mano sono
anche come si dice boxing number one
vai almeno 20 oggi red bull
come se non ci fosse un domani oggi
scambiamo roma roma sarà almeno 2.000
mega buongiorno già solo per farina cioè
non è possibile o per giulia penna di
due ragazze che non è così tanto giulia
penna che ti perche tiberio che mostrano
su marchetti per riprovare anche a 3
milioni e mezzo ma credo che vi mostro
nasco i 56 milioni celata non faccio
lunga ma si sa bene se l'infestante come
diventare magri velocemente cosa che a
me serve vai brasil quanto è
impressionato al pallone quest'uomo
dunque ragazzi una cosa impossibile che
io vado ht nuove siamo a nove tra
l'altro lower 10 dove vai quest'ora
grano pura anno e sicuramente più
visitato di comic book non sto
scherzando non fosse sì non lo so bacci
chiusura tua sorella morta papera che ha
10 vera che basta dire che per oggi va
bene così spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto l'aria con chi non so parlare
il banco di italiano quindi ci manca che
sono parlare le altre lingue però è
stato fino provarci
quindi ragazzo gli spray vi sia piaciuto
come si è riusciti un momento non mi
piace anche vari social che come ritorna
nella sezione chiudersi di siete lì ci
mettiamo un prossimo video per ragazzi
imparate le lingue da fa dj o a limonare
[Musica]